oh you know it's a good day when I get
to talk about hockey that means things
are right in the world UNLV hockey going
to the acha national championships in
Boston but they need your help to get
there Nick raboni is with us here from
the program to talk about a Gala that's
being held to try and raise money to get
the team out there the national
championships are in Boston and UNLV one
of the top teams in the country you got
to get there too uh thanks for joining
us first of all let's talk about this
event you guys are hosting this week
yeah thanks for having me so tomorrow
night we have our Rebels with the cause
Gala um it's going to be from 6 30 to 9
30 at a simple Affair in Summerlin
unfortunately right now tickets are sold
out however you can still bid on our
silent auction at rebelhockey.com that's
going to help us go a long way we got
some great prizes whether it's top tier
golf some Rebel hockey swag or or even
some Vegas golden knights signs and
stuff now for those who don't know I was
at the rebel game on Friday night tell
us about the rebel hockey program and uh
the involvement that it has with the
school it's not an NCAA program but
certainly is still very much involved
with the school it's not an NCAA program
but we pride ourselves in running the
program as if we were already there so
it is considered Club quote unquote the
school helps us out a little bit but our
budget alone is about five hundred
thousand dollars every year and this
trip to Boston is going to be upwards of
about fifty thousand dollars so we rely
heavily on our sponsors donors and the
community to to really help us reach
those goals and you guys one of the top
teams in the country what do you guys
ranked right now in the acha D1 yeah
three-ish we're ranked second right now
second okay 22 three and one you know
who's counting
um but it's been a great year yeah yeah
it's been a great year for us and our
guys have put in a lot of time and
effort and we've played some exhibition
NCAA D1 games this year to kind of help
us prepare for this National Tournament
run and you know the program has been
around for for a long time now but it
seems like it's made a lot of big
strides in the last few years what is
the energy like around you know for the
UNLV kids the students for you but
involved with the program really
accelerating things and getting College
hockey on the map here in town you know
we owe lots of Vegas golden knights we
wouldn't be where we're at today without
that practice facility having that
locker room and and having a place for
our guys to really call home but yeah
when you come to a game there's there's
not an atmosphere really like it I mean
there's 800 900 to 1000 fans packed in
City National Arena everybody's pounding
on the glass it's a really fun
environment and it's uh it's cheap
tickets you know you're looking at five
ten dollars to come to a game and uh I
think that the product on the ice gets
better every year finally if people want
to get involved you mentioned the gala
is sold out but if people want to get
involved in the auctions how can they do
that yeah rebelhockey.com or you can go
to 32auctions.com backslash Rebels with
a cause that'll take you directly to the
link and like I said we got some great
auction items on there we'll get that
information online as well Nick raboni
from the UNLV hockey program good luck
in Boston at the national championships
hope to uh see you guys come back with
the title and uh appreciate you coming
this morning thanks appreciate you
having me